today's questions from alex and nebraska
which is the better alternative buying a
starter home that you know you'll move
out of at some point or renting until
you have enough for your forever home
Alex I got bad news there are no forever
homes tada
when you buy your dream home you will
find out your dreams change your life
changes you add kids you take away kids
they leave you're empty nesters then you
get a little older and you might not
want stairs all of these different
things happen throughout the scope of
your life and there is no such thing as
a forever home the average home sells
every five point six years in America
and some of that is mobility but some of
that is just life changes or upsizing
we're downsizing we're upgrading we're
moving into a condo because we don't
want to grass anymore we're moving to a
big yard for the kids
oh we're sick of the big yard we want to
move in back and forth and all around
it's just part of life so buy your
starter home dude and then when you get
ready to move to the next thing move to
the next thing and get them paid for as
quick as you can get it paid off and
obviously if you can buy a home that
will suffice for the next several years
that's a good thing but there's nothing
wrong with getting a starter home get
your foot in the door on this wonderful
real estate market that we are
experiencing now this is the Dave Ramsey
show